Bộ nông nghiệp ở mù trường quy hoạt phòng trong tiên tay và thị lợi thời ghi hai nghị phòng trong hai mì mốt,
hai nghị phòng trong hai mùi tâm nhiên đến hai nghị phòng trong năm mưa hay giò thuộc trường phây dụi.
Và quy hoạt thị lợi lưu vực xong hồng sông thái mình, thời ghi đến năm hai nghị phòng trong hai mưa,
tâm nhiên đến năm hai nghị phòng trong năm mưa hay của mộ.
Và để sốt xây dựng đập xôn quan trên xong hồng, đập lắm tiêu trên xong đủng,
ra đó ở mộ nông nghiệp ở mù trường thống nhất việc nghiên cứu,
để sốt phần án xây dựng và đập xong trên xong hồng xong đủng xong đà phù hồng với các quy hoạt thị lợi đạo được phê dụi.
Mô để ghi, vánh dịch thịnh phóa nội nghiệp kiểu,
trên khai đầu tưu xây dựng và đập xong trên xong hồng xong đủng xong đủng xong đà bảo đam,
các một tiêu nhẹ vụ để ra đáp ứng hiệu qua về kinh tế, khi thuật góc phần đà bảo an ninh của nước,
thích ứng với đến đợi khi hồng, không làm anh hưởng đến khả năng thuật lụi,
ăn toàn để điều của hệ thống xong không làm giá tăng dùi gió thiệt tay không có y sản lợi bờ,
bài xong khu cửa thượng và hà liệu không làm hả thấp,
bực nước phía hà liều đập an hưởng đến khả năng lụi nước,
tiêu thân nước của các công trình lụi nước, tiêu thân nước, tại vánh xong không có yên bồi lập phía thượng
liều an hưởng đến mô trường xin thái, bù đúng nghiệp ở mô trường nhấn mạnh,
dương đập dân trên xong đà truyệt đối khu hòi an hưởng đến mực nước thấp nhất,
của nhà mại thử định hoa bên theo đúng thiết kế trong mò xong hợp và trở đô bệnh hành.
Đông thời bộ đề nghị hà nội lệnh giá khi tắc động trình trị xong,
rao thông thuy tạo luận cả đi, bố những ngồi nước, vẫn chuyển bồn gát và phù hợp với các nổi dùng tại thông bảo kết lộn của bộ,
và hà nội tạp bồi làm việc thực hiện dự án đầu tư, xây dựng trục đại lộ cạnh quan sông hông.